Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, I’ve got some fluids for you!
Most hobby projects with fluid simulations
involve the simulation of a piece of sloshing
liquid in a virtual container.
However, if you have a more elaborate project
at hand, the story is not so so simple anymore.
This new paper elevates the quality and realism
of these simulations through using mixture
theory.
Now, what is there to be mixed, you ask?
Well, what mixture theory does for us is that
it helps simulating how liquids interact with
fabrics, including splashing, wringing, and
more.
These simulations have to take into account
that the fabrics may absorb some of the liquids
poured onto them and get saturated, how diffusion
transports this liquid to nearby yarn strands,
or, what you see here is a simulation with
porous plastic, where water flows off of,
and also through this material as well.
Here you see how it can simulate honey dripping
down on a piece of cloth.
This is a real good one - if you are a parent
with small children, you probably have lots
of experience with this situation and can
assess the quality of this simulation really
well.
The visual fidelity of these simulations is
truly second to none.
I love it.
Now, the question naturally arises - how do
we know if these simulations are close to
what would happen in reality?
We don’t just make a simulation and accept
it as true to life if it looks good, right?
Well, of course not, the paper also contains
comparisons against real world laboratory
setups to ensure the validity of these results,
so make sure to have a look at it in the video
description.
And if you’ve been watching this series
for a while, you notice that I always recommend
that you check out the papers yourself.
And even though it is true that these are
technical write-ups that are meant to communicate
results between experts, it is beneficial
for everyone to also read at least a small
part of it.
If you do, you’ll not only see beautiful
craftsmanship, but you’ll also learn how
to make a statement and how to prove the validity
of this statement.
This is a skill that is necessary to find
truth.
So, please, read your papers.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!